joining us now exclusively he is the
chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee congressman Devin Nunez on the
issue of challenging the president's
executive authority it is very clear
constitutionally article 2 section 1
gives the president unfettered authority
over all executive branch matters the
executive power shall be vested in the
president in the United States this
isn't even in question is it it's quite
clear Sean it thanks for having me on
again as usual this is quite clear this
is not complicated we have seen most of
this information and I mean in terms of
the FISA it's only 20 pages all you have
to do is make a copy and send it out put
it on the Internet so there at this
point it I do not understand why this
hasn't been Declassified the president
said declassify immediately without read
action is there any national security
concerns no and we've heard this same
story over and over again the same
people that are out there that are
running around saying oh there's
national security concerns with this
we're gonna reveal some sources and
methods happen to be the same people who
are involved they're either covering up
for their agency or they are involved
and that's totally unacceptable and this
is why we have to continue to get this
message out to the American people that
have been force-fed this Russian
kool-aid this is just Russian kool-aid
that was force-fed on the American
people for two years to scare Sean but
you said the declassification will
explain the struck page insurance policy
explain that and what else will we learn
that you can tell us from when we get
the unredacted information well we
believe the insurance policy that many
people know about that was Texas there
was around August that there were text
messages on that August of 716 we but a
lot of people believe that that was
actually the the FISA itself on the
Carter page we actually don't believe
that we believe they were very concerned
about the dossier we believe they know
they were trying to schnook her the FISA
Court and fool the judges and they
needed something else
and so James Comey has called it a
mosaic of facts well we need to see the
rest of those facts and that's what we
want
released and Lisa Paige said for nine
months they were not able to find
anything and then we learned about a
media leaks strategy it seems to now all
be coming together isn't it does is do
you believe people in the highest levels
of the FBI and the DOJ committed crimes
against the United States and tried to
undo a presidential election well I
think many crimes could have been broken
and I have said this numerous times that
I don't know how do J and FBI
investigate themselves because they are
all implicated in this I'd like to see
them do that though these are not taking
action on it as it relates I want to
make another point the text messages
between all of them and text messages
they they were Cindy you don't get to
send out classified information on your
cell phone that it's not classified if
it's classified then right there and
then they should have they should be
held accountable because they broke the
law they were sending classified
information over over cell phones so
that should be declassified immediately
so look would you have I don't know that
I believe some of the news stories that
are out there however many news
reporters have now said that they are
stalling that people within the DOJ and
FBI are stopped and you will release the
key Russia Gate depositions before the
election I only have a second that's
that's correct yep all right mr.
chairman thank you for being transparent
we appreciate it